вступ до про втехів доступний усім
жодних обмежень за віком дорослим Навіть
легше У тебе є дві опції перша
перенавчитись підвищити кваліфікацію або
отримати нову навичку для цього вступати
до профтеху можна протягом усього року
друга опція з нуля опанувати професію
тут правила вступу Тіш що для
випускників шкіл вартість тривалість
навчання залежить від твоїх знань і
навичок здобути нову професію можна
навіть за кілька місяців навчайся за
власний кошт безкоштовно або за кошт
роботодавця Обирай професію заклад і
приходь до приймальної комісії більше
інформації на сайті мон та в наших
соцмережах